Portia's with us in dallas texas hi
Portia how are you hi how are you better
than I deserve what's up okay babe I
have an issue I am a single mother sighs
I did buy your book and I love the book
Total Money Makeover I have certain
loans totaling in about $68,000 I have
credit card debt in about fifty five
fifty five hundred five thousand four
hundred fifty cars that I pay for about
523 a month and I know about twenty
thousand on it I am needing to find out
how I can actually start this process I
do have the thousand dollars saved up um
but I don't know if I should be saving
money whenever they'll have their no
where right now we got to work on the
debt that's the first thing you do what
we teach folks to do is baby step 1 is
$1,000 and then baby step 2 is we list
all our debts smallest to largest we
stop saving and we stop investing and we
pile up and we don't we tear into that
smallest debt and get rid of it you need
to cut up your credit cards tonight all
of them home what is your income right
now my income is about 47,000 a year I
had a job making more but I was recently
laid off for about two months so I
picked up you know the nearest job that
I could get the quickest I've asked
again how much how much child support do
you have coming in it's about 14
thousand a year a year okay all right so
we're dealing with a $60,000 household
income that car is a very expensive car
mm-hmm it's not it's not where you have
to sell it but it's where you need to
think about possibly selling it and
moving down in car a $500 car payment in
your situation is a huge ouchie mm-hmm
ouch ouch ouch ouch ouch ouch it's going
to hold you back
I'm alcohol so it's not like you got a
high interest rate on it too
I do unfortunately and it was my first
car and I didn't know any
about 9 a car on my own so I'd love for
you to get about a $5,000 car for a
little while while you get this mess
cleaned up and get no payments just for
a little while but you're gonna have to
pull back on some stuff and lay into
this and then you can get this you can
get this moving it'll work for you
though hold on I'm gonna send you a copy
that book the Total Money Makeover to
show you exactly how to do what and when
to do it this is the Dave Ramsey show
[Music]